[Music]
when we started the Tribeca Film
Festival which we announced in 2001
right after nine eleven to really bring
people back to our neighborhood our goal
was to just bring as many people back
downtown as possible when we announced
the first film festival we asked Nelson
Mandela to come and speak our city had
been devastated a country had been
devastated by 911 and as filmmakers we
didn't know what to do other than
literally to put on a show and to try to
give to try to our neighborhood a new
memory to try to give New York a new
memory and he just couldn't go like
start running movies so men Mandela came
and he talked about when he was in
Robben Island when he was imprisoned
that the one night that he and his
jailers all look forward to it was movie
night it's when they could come together
and they could laugh about the same
thing they could cry about the same
thing and they were they were one it was
finding their similarities finding what
was human about each of them and no
matter what side of the door either one
was going to end up that at the end of
the night and I always think back to
that and the sense of community of
coming together as community to watch
something is actually extraordinary when
you look at the NEA and potential cuts
to the NEA and you look at what would
happen to PBS it's criminal okay the
arts reflect to a country what a country
is the arts reflect who we are as a
people and to lose that is losing part
of our
our soul you know the NEA has been you
know they've been other administrations
that have tried to cut the NEA before
but it's such a small amount in the
budget and it is again a reflection of
who we are as a people and no matter
where you are in the ecosystem of being
a filmmaker a producer and actor it is
always hard to get your project made it
is you know sometimes it happens very
quickly but for the most part it's never
easy well artists get by will we find a
way to make work yes but when I look I
talk to my friend Whoopi Goldberg some
of her early work was funded by the NEA
there is a wonderful piece on YouTube of
Mister Rogers talking to Senator John Oh
pest story explaining what he did as mr.
Rogers on PBS and it's just so charming
to listen to them you're going how can
you cut that one of the things is that
our best our best export becomes our art
shows or move our entertainment and I
remember reading a piece after it was
Nick Kristof writing about how when they
first went into Afghanistan and you know
in the 90s and people were digging up
their old be ours after the Taliban had
left at that time they were digging
going into the backyard and digging up
be ours and they were coming with their
dirty old BRS that they had buried and
and the titanic and cassettes of the
Titanic I mean they they love our they
love our movies they don't always love
us but movies do remain movie and I I
mean stories our stories become most
valuable exports
[Music]
you